Jesus Christ our Lord and Savior
excellent the American flag baseball's
my favorite sport here at sport Diesel's
my favorite sport also known as the
Stars and Stripes Jesus Christ our Lord
and Savior excellent now for something
new this is a national holiday called
Thanksgiving on the fourth Thursday of
every November families feast and think
about what they're thankful for which
ones said daddy do I have a daddy
of course you do
dr. Vogel balm filling does that mean
you're my mommy sure I can be your mommy
so you love me
I do
and you'll always take care of me always
it's okay we'll take care of her just
like the others today we had another
incident but this time the subject was
not driven by anger but by something
else altogether
I told dr. Vogel Baum that the subject
was obviously suffering from isolation
adduce depression but he didn't respond
he just told me to find another tutor
[Music]
mommy didn't tell you Wow
I'm your father
we
our family
[Music]
welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
gonna be my new video for the boys
season two teaser trailer they just
dropped a little while ago to preview
the new season in a breakdown of the new
storm front villain that we got our
first look at if you haven't read the
comic books obviously the boys is based
on Garth anuses comic book series storm
front is one of the worst villains in
the series just as bad if not worse than
homeland err so we'll break it down
we're doing an Amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite moment from the
boys on the video addressing the footage
during the trailer first you see home
Lander as a child getting indoctrinated
and it seems kind of like they're
brainwashing him which I like the way
they play with that because it makes
sense why he's so crazy in present day
he's so isolated from other people he
never really had anyone that he treated
like a mother and even though Vogel bomb
was effectively his father he only
viewed him through glass at most times
like when he's a baby before he learns
to control his powers you see all these
scorch marks all over the place like he
accidentally killed a bunch of people
diabolical and even when his middle
school age during a lot of this clip it
seems like he's knowingly killing a lot
of these people like oh they'll just
clean up the mess I can do whatever I
want well on the road to becoming the
full-blown psychopath that he is in
present-day
and more to the villains that they're
introducing during season two there's a
whole bunch of new characters but storm
front is every bit the psychopath
homeland er is and in the comics
homeland er is actually a derivative of
storm Land a lot of the genetic
engineering that went into building home
Lander so to speak because he was
genetically engineered came from stuff
that they studied using storm front but
then you have the tag at the end with
him meeting his son the sort of super
boy or twisted version of super boy now
that we have on the TV show in butchers
former wife or still wife technically
they didn't get divorced so there's a
whole lot going on here obviously
homeland er is trying to get butcher to
back off you hate me for a reason that
you shouldn't hate me because your wife
clearly cheated on you with me and this
baby was the product i think the twist
though is is the butcher's gonna spin
that on his head and try to use his son
against him because they've already
changed so much of the comic book plot
and part of the idea of homeland ER is
that he's almost unkillable not
completely unkillable but the idea is is
there's
no other superhero that's quite as
powerful as him in the world he is the
top he's sort of like their version of
the Sentry if you're a big Marvel comic
book fan someone who is so crazy
powerful but just a little deranged just
in terms of power levels Queen Maeve
they introduced this season obviously
had a relationship with homeland err for
a little while even though they couldn't
stand each other she's so much more
powerful than the other members of the
seven except for homeland err she's not
nearly as powerful as he is so she's
like the next best option if you want a
deterrent to take home Lander down but
so is storm front super powerful but not
quite as powerful as home Lander but if
you're not a big comic book reader storm
front as the name implies is meant to be
a parody of Marvel's Thor but also DC's
Shazam he can fly he has lightning based
powers but his origin is just as twisted
as home Landers if not more twisted so
home Lander was actually genetically
engineered in the United States in
present day the timeline of the boys is
a little bit different in the comics it
takes place a little bit further back in
history the whole idea of Vaud American
using compound V to create superheroes
started way back with German research
during World War two Vogel bomb used to
be a Nazi scientist he created
Stormfront and created compound B but
through Operation Paperclip a lot of
those German scientists wound up living
in the United States under new
identities in Vogel bomb wound up
working for Vaud America and creating
superheroes for them using compound V so
comic book Stormfront was a full-blown
Nazi he really loved what they were
doing and he was all about it but
because he's a superhero he doesn't age
the way that normal people do so the way
that vaud American spins these fake
backstories about the heroes they say
that Stormfront is actually a
reincarnated Viking when really he was
actually born during World War two the
version of the character that the show
is going with is gonna be played by I
Akash from you're the worst this is what
she looks like in costume with full
makeup her costume looks pretty close to
storm fronts comic book costume
obviously they toned it down because his
physique is so huge but it's the same
deal with homeland her homeland her on
the TV show is a little bit slimmer than
comic book homeland er the way the
showrunner talked about her character
made it sound like they might be
tweaking her backstory a little bit she
might not originate from World War two
but they did say that they would be
going with a lot of the themes of the
storm front character so they claim
she'll be a more modern-day spin on what
Nazi might be like or someone who used
to be a Nazi back during World War two
and is still pretty rotten in present
day but they said that she would be
rotten to her soul just like comic-book
Stormfront what a coincidence that the
actress just came from a TV show called
you're the worst because Stormfront is
definitely one of the worst
quote-unquote supers the first time you
meet the character in the comics in a
really big way you're actually getting
backstory from a tech knight who's sort
of a combination of Batman and Iron Man
in the comics in this really really
twisted backstory I don't know if
they're gonna do tech night they haven't
announced it but they did say that they
be doing payback so I'm assuming that
tech night will show up at some point I
know a lot of you comic book fans we're
asking about him on my earlier boys
videos he's got this weird brain tumor
that causes him to want to have sex with
objects and just pretty much anything
uncontrollably and it becomes this
weakness that Billy butcher from the
boys winds up exploiting trying to turn
him into an informant part of the beauty
of the butcher character is that even
though he doesn't have any superpowers
he's able to beat these supers with
information and he's able to turn them
to his site into informants so he can
find out about the weaknesses and plans
and goings-on of other teams when he's
trying to take them down his real
superpower winds up being information
early speculation about her backstory on
the TV show what they might do if they
don't want to go for the world war ii
germany origin story they might just say
that she was also created around the
same time that home lander was created
in wound up being almost as successful
you have to imagine this storm front
even though she's not quite as powerful
as home Lander is still head and
shoulders way more powerful than any
other superhero on planet earth but
comic book storm front was meant to be
the real world's first superhero and
we've all been joking about the hero
gasm for you comic book readers out
there hero gazon is an arc in the comics
where billy butcher and the boys try to
go exploit some of the supers while
they're at a retreat called the hero
gasm which is exactly what it sounds
like
all the supers trying to get with each
other in the nastiest possible way they
were joking about it during their press
junkets for season 1 at Comic Con this
past summer like oh yeah we're gonna try
and do it at some point season 2 and
people were like no way there's no way
you can get away with doing something
that crazy on TV for them it winds up
being a challenge because Amazon gave
them so much more money for season 2 so
that's why we're getting so many more
characters while they're doing the
payback team while we're getting storm
front and all the other characters the
reason why I'm saying confirmed payback
is because the crimson countess is gonna
be a character during season two you see
this poster that they showed from behind
the scenes she was a character that
belonged to the payback team as you can
probably tell even if you're not a comic
book reader she's meant to be a parody
of Marvel Scarlet Witch they've been a
lot of people that have theorized about
endgame being different from the comic
book version of endgame because this is
very clear arc that homeland er has and
even though he's kind of set up as the
main villain of the comic series right
now technically he's not the worst
character in the story so we might see
more of that in the background during
season two but they haven't said how
many seasons they're planning on going
and I still feel like the TV show
because it's changing so much of the
comics is really gonna lean heavy into
this
Superboy son that he has now he's not
something from the comic book that's
totally original to the TV show so I
think the whole idea that home lander is
now in love with the idea of being a dad
oh wow I can give this kid the father
that I never had but no surprise he
probably winds up being a pretty
terrible father in the Sun might wind up
hating him by the end of the series no
thanks to butcher probably trying to use
his son against him just early
speculation I just feel like butcher is
gonna try and use his son as a weapon
against home Lantern knowing that
there's nothing on earth that can really
take down home lander at least that he
knows about right now they also just
cast patton oswalt in a super-secret
role and i'm wondering if he might be
playing the legend because they didn't
do the legend during season one and he's
a pretty big character on the boys he's
meant to be a parody of Stan Lee in real
life he's even kind of drawn to look
like a Stan Lee type figure not someone
with actual superpowers but an
information broker that has information
in secrets on all the superheroes so a
lot of times when butcher needs specific
information about weaknesses that
superheroes have or where they're going
to be or what they're doing he goes to
the legend to get that everyone post all
your predictions for stormfront and
homeland earth during season two and let
me know if there's any boys videos that
you guys want me to make if there's any
big questions you guys have or videos
about specific characters or storylines
they finished filming next week so we
might get some more footage or promo of
some sort before the end of the year and
I'm hoping that they premiere sometime
by next summer but they haven't
confirmed when they're actually planning
on releasing season two while you wait
for everything click here for my video
on the boys season 1
click here for that brand new Star Wars
Episode nine rise of Skywalker trailer
in Easter eggs thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]